geoffery going back to before you were a
Hollywood screenwriter what made you
think you could tell stories on a
Hollywood level what gave you that
confidence or that feeling that
intuition that you know what this is
something I think I can do I think it's
the ignorance of the young you know I
talked to a friend of mine once it was
probably a couple years ago when I was
home and she said when I was like 8 or 9
she asked me what I wanted to do when I
grew up and I said I wanted to be a
movie star so I kind of always knew I
wanted to work in film I was growing up
thought I wanted to be an actor and I
went to New York to study acting
actually at the beginning of my career
and that didn't pan out really because
non-traditional casting wasn't a thing
back in the early 90s and they cancelled
the Cosby Show so then non-traditional
casting that was like your only place
said then English was my second favorite
subject and I'd been writing you know
from the time I was young I just always
would write stories and my English
teachers kind of my biggest inspirations
as far as school goes so I was like well
just write stuff to be in so that's kind
of why I said wait into writing but you
just when you're younger you don't think
of you know Hollywood does seem like
this far away magical place in a way but
you also are very naive about how the
movie business is so you think oh you
just you write something and somebody
likes it in and they go out and pick up
a camera they make it and then it comes
out in the theatres and that's kind of
when you're younger that's kind of all
you could think about you don't know
it's the whole like convoluted twisted
process of screenwriting and you know
getting something from page to screen
when you're young so you're kind of in
that magical like illusion land where
you did I can do it you know
so yeah that's again the writing wasn't
always my wasn't my first goal but but
moving working in movies has always been
pretty much just what I want to do my
whole life so that's kind of my only get
career game plan boy how small was the
town that you grew up in um we had like
that I think 100 students in her
graduating class I almost feel like I
should Google that I should know that it
was a very small town it took us it
wasn't for like a 40-minute bus ride to
get to school every day oh wow so we
were like the last stop out there down
the hills so it was Eastern Kentucky so
it was very small town they didn't have
a theatre program like my English
teacher when I was a sophomore I talked
her into creating a theater program for
once the the one year and then it kind
of died out after that year but yeah I
was I was pretty determined you know
it's very interesting when you're young
and you're driven because you that's one
of the things you try to tell people to
hold on to because it as you get a
little older you know that the drive
doesn't necessarily go away but it's you
know the realities of the business and
the distractions can kind of get your
way so when you're young you just have
that that boundless like energy and
faith and optimism and you know so you
try to hold on to that magic you know
even when you start getting into the
business side of things right because as
you get older you kind of talk yourself
out of it knowing all the things that
can go wrong right and it's almost a
shame I mean there's that just like at
this protective part that is there for
that reason but then yeah but you know
parent you know and it's nobody
encourages a career in the yards like if
you tell anybody we know you want to be
an actor or a writer or they're always
saying well you know that's great what
are you gonna do for a real job like
that's pretty much the reaction my mom
did not know that I majored in theater
in college till after I was in college
like I tell her I was majoring in math
and she got so mad she found out I've
made majored in theater because she's
like you're never gonna be able to make
a living doing that and you know so
there is a reality but for me like again
I just never had a back-up plan so you
know I think you know luckily I was good
at English and writing was was a another
passion of mine so I found a way to stay
in the business and not give up when the
acting didn't kind of pan out as soon as
I had hoped it would so but yeah people
like well usually tell anybody who says
they want to be in the film business or
any kind of art they're like oh that'll
be a good hobby what are you gonna do
for a real job and so that's kind of
just part of our society we don't really
value I think in in this country I think
in other countries they do value their
arts more than we do here but usually
arts programs are the first things to
get cut in schools you know it's like
sports number one then science and math
and stuff and then the arts are usually
kind of down here as far as his
priorities go which is it which is
interest because I think the arts are
probably one of the more helpful just to
help you as an even being to kind of
grow and like expand your horizons open
your mind and just you know also get in
touch with your emotions a lot of stuff
that it a lot of
other fields don't really emphasize or
help you do I think the arts that's why
a lot of people love the arts but um it
is you know that's something I think we
have to start valuing a lot more in our
country it's funny you mentioned sports
because I think I heard you say in
another interview and I laughed out loud
when I heard it that people that are
into horror probably weren't people that
were playing sports yeah yeah and they
weren't the cheerleaders and they
weren't the job yeah I thought that was
great because it's true you develop this
this interesting imagination that when
you're in that sort of herd mentality
trying to be popular all that probably
isn't isn't going through your mind so I
talked about that and there's a lot to I
mean you know if you're an athlete to
like that's your whole life like you're
always practicing you're always you know
when you're not at school practicing
you're practicing at home you're
watching what you eat you're working out
you're so that's your whole life so you
don't yeah I think you know most of the
people that I know are artists you know
they smell most their time at home like
you know watching movies or reading
comic books or you know doing kind of
nerdy geeky things like just you know
what you know really playing in their
imagination or with their imagination
and I think that's a kind of a common
thing you find you'll find with artists
you know a lot of artists will you know
didn't have like a big clique that they
hung out with or weren't really you know
super popular and some of them were but
but again it is you know especially in
high school it's because I know it's
like schools like a machine you know you
have so it's very important obviously
get an education but you have so many
kids going through every year that you
don't have time to like everybody's got
their own individual personality you
can't really get to know people so you
kind of have to shove them in boxes to
like you know just to process people
it's a you know it's a weird thing that
I've noticed as we grow up because
people still try to generalize you know
in a way and so that's even when I talk
when I Joe it's not even joking when I
talk about like you know the jocks and
the cheerleaders aren't the ones that
were home watching a lot of horror
movies it's also because they were out
practicing and doing sure their thing
but it's into how we still kind of keep
those boxes as we get older and you know
I sound a little like a hippie right now
but no no I found it I thought it was
funny because there's a lot of truth to
it so you know how many screenplays did
you write before final death
nation I think about seven and these
were feature yeah yeah seven features of
varying degrees starting from really
awful - okay - good
cuz that yeah I wrote my first one I was
in middle school no high school and I
sent it to Line Cinema to get coverage
on and I'm like oh I got great coverage
but it's not right for us and then when
I started working at new line like five
years later I dug the coverage up and
they were like this is awful
it was obviously written by a middle
schooler I was like I was in high school
so it's interesting because I that I
always just tell people like that's why
you you can't take rejection when you
get it because if I'd have seen that
coverage when I was that in high school
I probably would have just been like oh
I don't have any talent out of given up
but you also have to be open to growing
you know cuz I also meet a lot of young
people and you know God bus I'm you know
but they just they think that they're
already there they're like you know how
you know I'm like this script script is
the best thing you know Hollywood's ever
gonna make and it's like you're 15 I'm
sure that I'm with all due respect I'm
sure that's not the best thing that
Hollywood its kind of gonna read so you
know you need to kind of let your ego go
and realize it you have to have to grow
so I was very I wrote a lot um I didn't
again just learning you it's a learning
process but I just it was a foot when I
was young it was just a lot of fun you
know just to write and then you know you
start learning structure as you get you
know older and then when you start
working in a studio then all the sudden
you start realizing oh there's a hard
craft of this that you need to kind of
learn to so it's mixing the business
with the creative and this was a script
based loosely on like Nightmare on Elm
Street
that was one eye that was the treatment
I wrote when I was 14 which I wrote I'm
gotten to hello cat a little visitor
here that I wrote for a night run Elm
Street and that's what got me in touch
with New Line Cinema when I was 14 and I
stayed in touch with him till I was 19
and I started interning there when I was
19 and so yeah they made they made final
destination when I was 30 just to date
myself but um but um the first
finalization originally started off as a
spec script to get an agent for an
x-files episode because they want you to
write something you know of your own and
they also want you to write something
that's already on TV so that you can
show you can write different characters
voices so I wrote is a
files episode and I didn't submit it to
the show because when my friends at
newline said this will make a great
feature and then I worked on it and it
ironically ended up with two guys who
worked on the x-files James long and
Glen Morgan so it was kind of a I think
I think it was kind of a karmic thing
you know that's kind of meant to be with
the x-files connection there I'm curious
so what is keeping in touch was that
like that's fascinating Oh Morty neroli
yeah I'm just gonna be keeping in touch
with new line well no but well cuz that
you because I you know Bob Shaye at
first he didn't read my treatment
because it was unsolicited and then I
wrote him kind of a snarky not snarky
but you know kind of a you know I was
like hey I've seen three of your movies
and I spent money on you I think you can
take five minutes to read my story yeah
yeah so so he did and you know got back
to me and and then his assistant would
you know her name is joy man she's like
just amazing woman would you we had she
passed years ago unfortunately but just
amazing woman and she would send me like
movie posters and like little you know
merchandising things for the movies that
she was sending scripts to read so I
just would stay in touch with them and
send them scripts and you know they were
always very very gracious to even spend
time with me and when I they I don't
know if they ever knew I was actually
gonna get to New York or not but I ended
up at my collar I was pretty crafty I
should be craftier I make a good
supervillain if I if I use my craziness
for evil but um when I was in college we
started I had to do a special program
where I could go to New York for the
summer to study at the American Academy
of Dramatic Arts and then would get
credit for it so they the school paid
for my whole trip to New York and my
whole summer there but then I got an
internship at new line while I was up
there and got an agent I was like ah
screw school and decided to stay to stay
in New York and stay at new line so so
that so it was they knew you were 16 or
however old you were when you sent the
script in yeah I think yeah joy I think
I don't know if I heard I don't know
when I told Joe how old I was I think
she asked me one because I I would call
her - I got the phone number from
information so I would just call her and
she would say she would talk to you
that's right yeah I mean and this was
back when new line was you know I mean
nightmare had come out so they were they
were definitely growing but they hadn't
turned into like the powerhouse that
they that they became but um you you
know it definitely wouldn't that
wouldn't happen today but um you know it
was a real blessing I mean I you know I
always give credit to Bob and enjoy for
you know just if they hadn't stayed in
touch with me and inspired me and then
brought me on as an intern when I first
started you know in when I went to New
York I mean I'm sure I still would have
been in the business like that just was
my path I think but um but yeah they
were they were really crucial and I'm
missing I mean Warner Brothers like
absorb a new line so it you know it's
not the same place anymore but it was it
was probably one of the best I think
studios probably to ever be built
because it was so artist friendly and
you know they really cared about like
the B Bob Shaye was a huge film lover
like he started distributing like John
Waters films out of his apartment to
college campuses and doing like these
tour like so he's a huge film lover so
he created this company that was full of
film lovers and now you have a lot of
great companies but a lot of them are
run by business people who don't love
film so they they understand the
equations of like you know well if I put
this formula together it'll make money
but they don't understand the creative
side of it and new line was just just a
wonderful like fostering environment to
work so yeah I got really lucky with
that one so your first year there as an
intern you were 19
yeah do you remember what that was like
I mean it must have been surreal because
here's this group of people that first
they turned you down but then they keep
in touch with you and they send you
things and now you're there it's some
it's it was it was surreal in a way but
it was kind of it's a weird thing
because just because I always knew I was
gonna be working in the movie business
somehow like I didn't get except I
wasn't like super I can't would hit me
sometimes but it didn't hit me when like
when I found that coverage for that
first thing I wrote it I was like wow if
I'd have read this if they did tell me
the truth I might not be here but
because it was kind of all happening and
you're again when you're younger you
know you're so like 19 you're still at
that like I can do anything in the world
and I think it's not me and you know so
I never I always have always been so
appreciative of the opportunity but I
wasn't like I was ever surprised you
know but it was cool it was really cool
like because I never got to meet all the
people from Nightmare on Elm Street and
so meeting all these people that I had
grown up idolizing was like cool and I
remember we were at the 7 new line did
you know
17 this amazing movie with Brad Pitt and
Morgan Freeman and we're at the premiere
for that and I'll send him talking to
Morgan Freeman for like an hour around
like you know because they teach you
when you work they're like don't act
weird around when the celebrities come
in because they would come in all the
time for meetings so you just said that
you'd learn how to like kind of shut
that geeky part off of your brain right
right sometimes but then I you know I
had lunch with Jane babbler who was in V
the miniseries that came out in the 80s
and played Diana the the evil like
lizard alien queen and that I liked I
had lunch with her and that was the
first time I've actually been starstruck
where I like I couldn't talk like it was
read it because I never knew what
starstruck meant until I had lunch with
her and then I was like I can't talk
right now and I can't this is really
embarrassing I'm a grown man and why
might like this but yeah it's it's um
again it was it was it was a wonderful
thing and it was a wonderful convergence
of again the right people like Bob enjoy
like taking the time because even you
know Bob could his hurt and in that one
thing and written me off and joy could
have been like oh that's cute and you
know but you know she did she would stay
in touch with me I probably just
probably I probably bugged the hell out
of her I was always like hey do you read
this can eat it and she was just very
patient and yeah just it was yeah it was
a wonderful experience
yeah it was so then if I understand this
right that final destination was the
first screenplay that you actually sold
first one that was the first one I sold
I wrote one it never got made but I was
actually hired to write a sequel for a
movie called Pumpkinhead which is one my
favorites and they're remaking it now so
hopefully I can use my sequel idea for
the sequel for the remake but I got
hired actually before I had an agent I
got hired because Brad krivoy was a
producer and yeah he was taking pitch
meetings and I wrote a pitch that he
liked and he basically hired me in
another writer right Dreyse of the
script and then they ended up the
company got bought by somebody and all
this so neither one of our scripts ever
got made but no that was my first paying
job as a writer which was fun that was a
little crazy because you're like wow I'm
writing something that I grew up loving
so that was the first thing that I
actually sold and I and I'd written like
five or six seven scripts before before
a final destination that never
got and rightly so for some of them when
you go back and read them it's like whoa
these are pretty pretty bad but there's
a couple of this I would like nuggets of
ideas that I might turn into something
someday so then what I'm just wondering
how how did it happen what was the what
were the details so you're working at
new lines
oh no years you know me for years you
know I had the TV I was trying to get a
TV agent and then my friend Mark Calhoun
was like oh this would make a great idea
for a feature so I back in the back in
the day you could actually sell a
treatment to a studio you know you
didn't have to write a whole script and
because I worked at the CIA I knew how
the when the winds would change very
frequently like it so you know something
would be hot one week and not the next
week so I was like well let me write a
treatment because it's a great concept
and then I'll some friends of mine
worked for a producer outside of the
studio that had a deal with the studio
someone could let me work with him and
their producer partner and bring the
idea back to the studio because I knew
that would give me a better chance of
getting it set up it was what the
producer attached so I you know had the
treatment but then and it was about they
were all adults and then scream came out
and I love scream and Kevin Williams is
a dear friend of mine but the minute
that came out of Psych well let's make
them all teenagers so then I had to go
through and rewrite the treatment to
make them teenagers and then sue there's
like they just couldn't get their head
around death being the killer if they're
like this it's a great it's cool but how
can you make death a killer you that
just doesn't make any sense I'm like
that's the whole point like it's it's
death you can't so
they Pat they the Souter just kept
passing on it and finally the producers
it was Warren's IDE and Craig parry they
were like well if you don't if you pass
on it again we're gonna go to dimension
which was kind of new lines rival
Miramax at the time it said they're like
we'll buy it so then they bought the
treatment then they hired me to write
the jerk there's the first route of the
script and then we went on to directors
after that so it was a pretty quick
process and we sold the original story
97 and movie came out in 2000 so that's
a in Hollywood time that's pretty pretty
fast so when you did the casting for it
how did you find the lead they actually
new line did all they all the casting
through their casting Department I mean
I you know I'd put a little list
together like my dream cast at the time
but you know I loved the cast that we
ended up with and it's funny because I'm
friends with Devon
you know he's directing now and he's got
a new TV show on and so I directed his
or produced his first short that he
directed he's really talented guys so
we've actually reconnected in the last
few years and he's just a he's just a
great guy but um it is funny because
when I was writing the movie I was kind
of you know trying to turn some of the
tropes on their heads and so there's you
know there's very few movies I had like
a final guy and it's always a final girl
so I wanted to write a movie like a
final guy in it and his character I
think is definitely stands out as you
know he's such a great actor too did a
great job and he was Casper so as always
it's just very funny making fun of him
because he was in Casper floating around
with Christina Ricci and her kids dance
ridiculous Devin
I would see him in so many things like
because I used to go into blockbuster
all the time yeah I'll just remember you
know there he was again yeah so yeah but
at that time was he yeah he was really
he was really he was really hot then too
I think he dumb he dumb oh man there's
something North blank on the name of it
but um there's a group of there was some
coyotes and kids in them I ain't gonna
move yet but it was it was it was a
really big man it was Casper and then
they that when he did idle hands
I think idle hands might have been I
know if that was pre or post final
destination I think it might even post
final destination but yeah he was
definitely like on everybody's like yeah
you know ones to watch list so and we
shot in Canada so we got a lot of
Canadian talent for the film as well
does horror screenplay structure
different from drama I don't necessarily
think so I mean I think all screenplays
kind of follow the basic three act to
kind of save the cat kind of structure I
think the biggest of with horror is is
they do want kills pretty frequently so
you know the the standard rule is like
every 10 pages they want to have either
a really scary scene or a kill so in
drama it's not like you have to have
like a super dramatic moment every 10
minutes like you can have you can build
the drama you can still do that in
horror as well but a lot of times just
the formula at some point you know I can
take a media project I've been over
there like it's been a while since
somebody died yeah nobody's died here in
a while so uh they want to throw another
death in there so then you guys had a
didn't care
to kill off so but you know I think all
of the screen you know it's like I think
comedies are very close to horror cause
it's always building up to a joke and
horror you're building up to a kill but
with comedies that's a lot it's a lot of
you know more jokes and with horror
again you have more of a pacing with
your with your kills but they all do
follow the same general structure but
usually you know the joke and horror
when it's like well what's this
character's motivation it's like to get
away from the guy with a knife you know
it's like that's pretty much it or well
I'm dating myself with all this but I
think it seems like Friday the 13th
there were definitely more kills but if
you look at like carrier which I know
you brought that up yeah she doesn't
really get her revenge until the very
end which it would have been nicer to
see her do it sooner right rather than
the Exorcist I guess a long time yeah
that's a almond was pretty that's a
thing is like they don't yeah movies and
it's all but they blame it come online
on a DD now everybody's like you know so
overly you know overloaded with
information that they can't concentrate
so that they act like the quiet movies
don't work anymore but then you see
something like get out which was
definitely not like a Gore fest at all
or even like the early conjuring films
like didn't have like you know a lot of
like it wasn't like a kill every 10
minutes so people still want to go see a
good story and they liked suspense and
dread but it really depends on what what
you're writing if you're writing a
splatter kind of Friday the 13th movie
which for that one they just want blood
and pretty people getting hacked up and
or if you're doing like a conjuring
which is more like they want people want
to go on you know just fill that dread
and jump and scream and you know without
the body parts lying around
right I think Nightmare on Elm Street
too there was many more kills but I was
covering if the kills have increased now
because of you know you're saying yeah I
think it it depends on the filmmaker
like I think if a studio is behind
something they definitely want to kind
of stick with formula and make sure I
mean I've had that note on a couple
projects ever written I did I did I'm
finishing one for a French company and
they're they I have more Leo with him
because they're you know they let me
develop the character a little bit more
than I think I would if this was if it
was an American film but I still have
enough good scares in there but there's
not a lot of like gore
and I again and I love writing gory
stuff and I love writing a non gory
stuff too so I think it's just fun to
try to scare people in ways that I
haven't seen them get scared before
how important is screenplay structure to
your overall writing I mean is there a
specific structure you try to follow I
try to I found because I I kind of
learned how to write through reading a
ton of scripts like a new line I was
there to read all the scripts all the
time so I find that most of my stuff
does kind of fall into the you know
traditional like three act structure
save the cat thing or that's the
inciting incident I don't get into
there's some stuff and I shouldn't roll
my eyes at it because people do but you
know there's some books that are like
well you have to have they have like
they've broken down it like super micro
science and for me it's just like too
much like you know in a way you don't
wanna be at the creativity out of
somebody by giving you too much of a
structure you know I think that's why I
think the three-act structure is enough
or yes you know at the end of your
second act something's got it like
propel you into the third act and you
know things have got to get you know
more intense and more intense to your
finale but you know I think a lot of
times even like I have a lot of friends
I go to film school and their one thing
is like they're like I wish I had spent
that money to make a film because they
just they're like we would have learned
a lot more and it's not you know
anything against going to film school
but it's just again if you're trying to
teach somebody somebody whose artistic
how to you can teach them how to channel
that into a format that's going to be
more palpable to the masses but if you
start getting too much into like you
know page 20 this has to have been on
page 30 this has to happen then you're
like stifling people's creativity in a
way but there is a reason if there is a
structure like that sometimes because I
had friends give me a script in it like
the first drafts like a hundred and
forty pages I'm like I'm not right this
is not a script it's like a miniseries
like they're like oh but if you
understand it's like if they can tell
the Titanic and 120 pages I'm sure you
can tell your story about a woman who's
trying to find true love in her small
town in less than 140 pages so you know
there there there is a wisdom to the
basic structure but all when I sit down
to write something usually I start with
a concept
I'm very concept driven just because I
think that's working at a studio for so
long I know that the concept is what's
going to get people's attention or not
get it so I start with using a concept
and then I think of some scares as well
and then start you know with building a
story around the concept it's how I
approach you but I know a lot of people
start from like characters and some
people start from a story so it's
everybody's got their own personal kind
of creative style and how they um how
they work but for me I always I always
start with the concept of the story and
I try to think at least some concept
that's kind of high concept that you can
kind of if you tell somebody in a minute
and they're like all that sounds cool
you know so that's that's kind of where
I start off when I'm writing what do
studio executives and producers say
about story structure or do they not is
it just this isn't working here or do
they narrow it I think it depends I mean
it's every studio so different now and
the studios of honestly they've changed
so much since when I started off like I
said a lot of them you know are run by
business people with no creative
background at all so you know they're
you know it sound like they're relying
on their creative team and that's not
that's not every studio buddy by any
means but but it has got a lot more
business oriented so I've been in a lot
of meetings where it's like it's this
isn't working for me I don't know why
but it's just not and they so they don't
know they just know that they don't like
it and so then you have to like try to
fish around to kind of figure out what
they don't like about it or what's not
working for them and and a lot of times
it's it's it's just a very interesting
business because you meet somebody
interesting type-c made some really
great smart creative people but you also
meet some people who got their jobs and
then you're like how does this person
like working you know I don't understand
because they obviously know nothing
about film and I'm gonna even saying
that like some of it's like sometimes
ridiculous where they'll say what can
you put like can you make all the people
13 it's like well they're carrying
machine guns that is in fighting
monsters so that might look a little
ridiculous with the 13 year old minute
machine gun like well just try it you
know so a lot of times you'll get nails
like that or they'll give you a really
crazy note that will derail your like I
don't think a lot of people understand
like you know what you do knit a
screenplay together so if ya if you pull
string out over here it does have an
effect in other places a lot of times
they'll be like well just you know my
the producers sister wants a part so
just give that girl a best friend and
just put her in once and like well then
it wouldn't be her best friend if she's
only one scene
but then that affects all this other
stuff and they don't we'll just make it
work so you'll get that a lot of times
or it's like they'll give you like a
really crazy note so what I've learned
to do over the many many years now is is
you have to be a little
passive-aggressive with them you have
you because they do at the end of the
day everybody working in the business at
least wants to be heard and you try to
again decipher what their note means if
their note sounds stupid like if they're
if they're saying you know well if
they're just telling you to put
somebody's friend in the movie that's
that's not a creative no but if they're
like well we see there just needs to be
a cat we just want to I want a cat here
and you're you try to think well why do
they feel it so important I have a cat
here and then it's like oh okay maybe
there's like some emotion that's missing
here or there's like you know because
when you see a cat it just gives you the
warm fuzzies that maybe there's
something that's missing in this scene
that they want so other times if you go
back to them and you say well I you said
you wanted a cat here but what I think
you were going for was that you're not
feeling this in this and it's not like
yeah that's what I mean
so a lot of it is kind of deciphering
what what they say but as far as
structure itself goes I mean they'll
they'll know structure a lot of times
but other times it's like it's committee
stuff so you know they'll have a reader
cover script first you know so if the
reader doesn't like it then autumns
won't even go to a development executive
or creative executive critically the
executive likes that they'll give to
somebody higher up if somebody ups
higher up it's like it likes it they'll
put it on their weekend read which means
that all the executive team will read it
and that's still a roll of the dice if
they're gonna let you know so it's it's
a it's a tough business but the great
thing is there's so many other companies
out there besides the major studios that
you can go that's why I always tell
people to focus on because um getting
into the studio just really hard because
it really it's a machine now like and so
they're all putting out remakes and
sequels and things based on comic books
and video games and so all the original
content goes to there you know if Chris
Nolan wants to make inception yes they
will give him money but then they're
like well our slots full you know you
know we've got all of the Marvel movies
coming out for five years now and one
one movie that's not a Marvel movie so
yeah they don't care so much about
structures it's more of the business
model I think Oh a lot with the studio's
so you learned that in that it helps you
take your ego out a lot of stuff so you
don't take it personally because it
really it really is a business I think
they do care more about business models
and they do
structure do you know when that changed
I mean I realized you probably can't say
yes it was 2001 oh yeah no I mean I
think it I think it started to change in
the 90s you know I think it started
changing and like because I think when I
start working at new line it was in the
early 90s and it was those I think it
you know 60s was very clot of times I'm
you know 60 70 I think a lot of that was
creative but I think in the nineties as
I think when a lot of the corporations
started wanting to be in the movie
business so then you had like you know
Ted Turner buying like you know the
studio and then you know Warner Brothers
buying the studio and then then
everything too started turning into big
corporations and you know then when
you're it doesn't you know this is no
offense to business people when you're a
business minded that's all you think
about is your bottom line that's like
well how can i Matt you know how can I
take off as many boxes to make sure this
movie has the widest appeal as opposed
to like if I make this really good movie
even though I don't get it at all
you know I'm gonna take a chance on it
cuz I trust that there will be enough
people that will watch it like that's
why I Love New Line Cinema you know cuz
Bob Shaye really fostered that it was a
very maverick you know thinking back
then and Mike DeLuca was one of the
really one of the best development
executives I think that ever worked in a
studio I mean he was you know he would
do a movie and you know like a movie
like blade he would be like he wants to
see a black Vampire Slayer well a lot of
people you know who wants to see a movie
about a guy that puts on a mask and he's
you know can do this great who wants to
see him you know like about these two
really dumb guy you know he would come
he would really champion all these
movies that most studios would never
ever take a chance on but he got the he
got it he's like no I'm trust you have
to trust me on this like people will go
see these movies and you don't see that
that I'm fearless as much anymore
in studios and that's just they just
like to play it safe and that's you
again you can just see it from their
slates that's why they're you know
they're remaking remakes now and you
know the thinking is well if it's if
people know the title then that gives us
a leg up over an original film so it's a
safer business proposition so it's kind
of that's why I love people we might
going to TV now is because that's where
you can go and be creative and you know
they're spinning almost as much on TV
they're spending on movies now and you
can have a really great creative
storytelling and not be like stifled so
back when you were at new line do you
remember the that people would know sort
of character arc and and it was much
more about the craft of writing that
they could understand and dissect
certain parts and why they didn't like
it do you remember um yeah no I think I
think in like yeah I think in the
develop meetings there was definitely
like there was stuff that people the
notes were definitely much more like
this isn't working because of yeah it's
not the creative stuff isn't being
satisfied in it whereas later on I was
just like I don't like it or there's not
a big actor attached or I can't make a
toy out of it but you know even new line
they started a vision called fine line
that was more for their art house films
that didn't you know fit the traditional
blockbusters you know structure or you
know would probably win an Academy Award
but would probably not make a lot of
money so they created a division
especially to let like auteur filmmakers
do their thing you know without having
to worry about is this going to make a
hundred million dollars at the box
office or not
so yeah they were that was part of the
just a film lover kind of company like
creating like an offshoot to make like
kind of artsy films that most people
would read the scripts would be like
what is this Helen Hunt with a piano and
her daughter sitting on a Milano where
what does it make any sense so do you
remember the first movie you saw in the
theater
um I don't actually which is really
really weird I remember seeing that on
Elm Street when a in in 84 in Kentucky
in Kentucky I remember seeing that when
you were there sorry to interrupt but
yeah I think okay I were you already
thinking of writing this other script no
I just thought this is the best movie
I've ever seen in my life because it was
a double feature it was like alone in
the dark which new line put out as well
which was a slasher movie about some
escaped mental common you know mental
patients who get out during a storm one
night Jack Palance was in it and
terrorized like a town in this house and
and so nightmarish it was a second movie
after that so the first one was scary
but it was I mean now straight when you
touch when you're 14 is like it was just
brilliant like I was like what the hell
is this movie so just kind of blew my
mind so it's it is funny almost I mean I
remember seeing like so
slod on TV but it is funny as far as the
movie theatres go for some reason my
brain is just oh no I do remember I know
this isn't the first one I saw this is
awful but they used to do these like
these are these movies and they were
they were rated R movies but they were
stupid like pom-pom girls or something
some cheerleader pop so my cousins and
my mom of all people is my mom was a
little bit of a hippie they would take
us to the drive-in and they would sneak
us in but they would make us turn our
backs to the screen during any nudity
stuff but but we'd sit with like a
little pig I remember I remember I don't
remember the name of the who it was
something in the pom-pom girls are some
cheerleaders that I think that was the
first drive-in movie I remember seeing
that I remember least me and my sisters
from the most sort of time with our back
to the to the scream eating eating
popcorn and hot dogs and stuff but um
yeah I remember that because we had a
they had to sneak us in the theater
under him nice thinking good old hippie
[Laughter]
if you were to get notes and maybe they
wouldn't put it in these terms but to
dumb down a script oh yeah had that
happen oh you have okay in those exact
words okay so what is dumbing it down
and what would that be and what is like
braying raising the vibration if you
want to use it yeah term no I mean um I
wrote a script and returned to Cambodia
like actually it was a TV movie and it
was a sequel and Jed Nelson was in the
first one and so they got the him back
and the director back based on my script
and literally the one of the creative
executives like called the producer
probably about a month before they
started shooting and was like you know
we think the scripts just too smart for
our audience so we're gonna bring
somebody into to dumb it down and so all
that meant was that they just went for
the very generic with the characters and
just the base generic stuff so it's like
it was based on a the first movies based
on the killer who needed inspiration so
he started murdering people and he lived
in a cabin by the lake and would murder
people women and drown them in the lake
and then he would write about it so I
wrote a script that was about the making
a movie about the the first movie so it
was kind of very screamish and so like
in my script this is one simple innocent
but in my script
like he was dating the lead actress it's
all these other actresses like throwing
themselves at the director and he was
like in love with the leading actor so
he in there like what you know he should
be sleeping with all the actresses I'm
like but that's like the obvious that's
just knows obvious stereotype like I'm
trying to do something different so they
made you know so that's a dumbing it
down it's like going for just the base
like simplest thing we can do with no
nuance and I think if you if you when
I've gotten notes that the script needs
to be elevated it's just because I
haven't done enough work on the
characters you know there's not there's
not enough depth their interactions
their interactions maybe you're very on
the surface in some scenes or the
story's very maybe those points in the
story they're very on the nose so I
think they're I think nuance is usually
when they want when I'm asked to elevate
something see a bit add more layers or
to add more nuance to something but yeah
dumbing it down I mean that was a prime
example where it's just like they
they're like he should just be sleeping
with everybody because you know he's a
director and the producer should be
doing coke and that you know so it was
just and so it was and so they brought
one of their people on today like they
didn't even tell me and the producer
would not even ask him to send me this
screener that the script and she's like
I can't I'm like is it that bad she's
like I can't I'm here watching with some
friends I was like I was in there like a
little tear like that in the end when
you lit her like on the side but I like
a little tear went down my eye was like
wow but it's it's pretty funny watching
it I mean it's it's a camping movie so
in the director I think once he saw I
think he cuz he signed on based off my
original script and I think when he saw
this change companies like screw it I'm
just gonna make this like a comedy and
so he just like went really over-the-top
and gonzo with like the sound effects
and everything so it's almost him was
shot like a comedy version of a horror
movie so it's it's pretty interesting to
watch now I don't I should have kept a
copy it's like selling on eBay for like
a hundred and some bucks now bro I know
I was like wow I should have kept
economy and every thought about it so do
you get more notes to dumb something
down or to flesh something out um I get
more notes at the writing stage to flesh
this out but and I think one thing is I
want to production that's when things
start getting you know expecially in
horror movies they're like we need to
get to the kills quicker like that's the
kind of the common note that I get
for horace we need to get to the kills
quicker so any jokes or character stuff
that they can cut out they'll try to cut
out just to get to the kills quicker so
I wouldn't even say it's dumbing it down
unfortunately I would say it's you know
they just want to get right to the to
the blood and the murder or so is there
a time frame when the movie starts you
know like within 30 minutes there should
be conflict or whatever's yeah same
thing is there yeah with Rome's it's
usually there's usually you having a
death in the opening of a horror film
and then you know ten ten minutes and or
fifty minutes and you have another one
and you you kind of keep up they want
you to keep up a steady tick with them
so it's some interesting what movies
don't do that and I've certainly written
stuff where there there hasn't been a
death in the opening but then people you
know you start watching it and it's like
people want to get to that death quicker
so if you test market it or you or do a
test scream out test my buddy test
screen the film people might be uh took
a while to get to that first kill or it
started off boring and they're like okay
they want you know so sometimes the
answer is actually just shoot of death
seemed to stick in the beginning of it
see get it out of the way yeah because I
would buy you some I've learned to do
that now like cuz I've tried in other
films not to do that and I've just
learned that if you if you open with a
really big death that will give you a
lot of like real estate to it build your
story and so cuz people will still be
thing about that death for a good five
or ten minutes and so you've got some
time like build characters and not have
to jump right into another one right
away so instead of the hero's journey
the serial killers turn right there's
different things that they need to
follow as well yeah and then too in
terms of the the evil character are is
there times when you know it you're
making him to humanized or to to likable
can you tone them down and make them so
you don't know what the motive for yeah
I mean I've I've written a couple of
like thriller kind of horror movies and
I think you want for me it's like you
want to either have a villain that that
just terrifies everybody completely or
is a fun villain because they kind of
relish the bad stuff they're doing so it
depends on what kind of killer they are
I mean you don't want to romanticize
your killers like if you know
and I might try to stay away from even
though I watched him and I love them but
I try to save more like the torture II
like you know let's like let's tie a
woman up and like torture for ten
minutes and that's how a guy open
towards him for ten minutes like I tried
to stay away from that kind of so cuz it
just doesn't hold my interest for very
long when I was young it did because it
was bloody and that's all I cared about
but but you know if it's a killer like
that you don't want to humanize them I
don't think because it doesn't because
in your in this weird place where it's
like okay I'm just watching this person
like torture people for 90 minutes and
now you're trying to make me have
sympathy for them and you know it's
again there's enough of that in real
life like there's enough Shore you know
there's just enough really bad people
out there in real life though I think
when you go to watch them horror movie
you want to be like scared in your
tained
but it's still you want to escape I
think you you don't want to go there to
be reminded of like real life stuff so
yeah real life sociopath is gonna be
like the neighbors like oh he was such a
nice guy even though he's quiet and he
was chopping up people so it's like you
don't want to necessarily have that be
urgh you're killing in a horror film
well going back to Carrie though you
could see why she got to that stage yes
and you just like you had said and I
felt the exact same way I wish he'd gone
to that stage earlier yeah
but so I think with Carrie you were able
to feel maybe more empathy yeah and she
was never I mean cuz it kept they kept
had John Travolta numb oh my gosh I'm
blanking on the character's name but the
mean you know the girl ya mean girl and
you know so you had the villains who
were actually so she was still she was
always the hero that just got pushed to
the breaking point and so you get you
can have it I think somebody like that
you can have somebody who we get to see
turned dark because of the circumstances
they're put into but if it's a kind of a
traditional horror movie you've got like
the good you know the good person versus
the the evil killer like I think there's
you want to you want the audience to
maybe understand where the person's
coming from but if you get too far into
where they sympathize with them like I
think that's one of the reasons the one
of the disagree to me my friends have
about the movie don't breathe you know I
thought it was beautifully shot and well
done but I thought the Proby I won't
spoil anything for anybody I thought
that the protagonists the kids were
very unlikable and then I thought the
antagonist they went too far to make you
sympathize with why he was doing what he
was doing like when you you know but the
whole set up this is in the previews but
when the whole setup is three kids are
gonna go bot go rob a blind veteran you
know that kind of you're kind of set up
some character that you're like yeah we
don't really like and then you find out
this isn't a spoilery but the money he's
got the money because his daughter got
killed by a drunk driver so it's like
okay you're really bad people no like
you're robbing from a blind veteran who
has money because his daughter got
killed by a drunk driver
so it's hard to you know so they throw
him beat they throw in moments in the
movie where they try you know flashbacks
or scenes where they try to make you if
they try to force you to feel like some
sympathy for the characters but it for
me it just didn't you know I was just
like you look you lost me at the
beginning and then they didn't they made
the villain so so sympathetic that you
actually get I wanted him to like end up
just killing them at the end of it which
is not I don't think what you want a
movie when do you start writing everyday
about 11 o'clock I usually roll out of
bed and have my routine we're all you
know say some prayers meditate a little
bit not much read the news see what's
going on and pack up and you should go
over the coffee shop and start writing
so but I'm also a night out too so I
stay up late writing so it's it's
sporadic them because I'm usually
working juggling like four or five
different things at one time so I'm kind
of hopping usually hopping around to
make sure I'm kind of on top of whatever
needs to be done first how long are you
writing for it sound often - pretty much
all day I mean you know I'll be up late
watching TV but still have my laptop on
writing a little bit so you know I it
depends if I have a writing assignment
and I'm I'll be more structured in it in
fog that I'll make sure that I focus on
that and then try to like have fun
didn't have a life the rest of the time
that I'm not writing but if I'm in a
stage where I'm like working on four or
five different things trying to get them
off the ground then I'm just I'm usually
writing quite a quite a bit so you go to
the coffee shop do you ever write here
apartness
sometimes but if I stay here I get very
destroyed
like it's you know I want to watch TV I
want to take a nap you know very
comfortable here so I like to go up to
the coffee shop cuz they get my
socializing done too because I you know
have friends there and stuff like that
so I like to get out and do that as well
there's a lot of regulars there that we
have to oh yeah yeah there's a lot of
them self thanks a lot of writers do
they ask you what you're writing on or
no one really asks that they just kind
of know people yeah people will talk to
you and especially if you go there a
long time and you've made friends with
people they they kind of know what
you're up to and you know they follow
you on social media in your time on
stuff they'll be they'll ask you about
what you're doing and things like that
so yeah it's it's a pretty it's fun it's
you know it's very transitory though too
because there's a couple of regulars but
you know a lot of the writers will you
know if they moved and they'll go to
another coffee shop or they'll go work
it like the WGA has a you know space to
work at or people like rent spaces now
which I'm actually think not doing
because I think I broke it down and some
I forgot what the place is called but
there's a company where you can like
over in a space an office space and
Cameron Bure any of these names but I
did the math it's like oh well for the
cup of like a Starbucks coffee and done
it every day
I could actually rent this place for a
month and they have free coffee all day
but I I drink tea so no no I have to
check to make sure they have tea it's
only not as good as Starbucks no no but
it's like it's a cool like you can get
like a desk and like a run shooter do
you have your own little spot so it you
know it does if you're actually leaving
your place to go to work it does kind of
put you in a different mindset because
even if I'm walking in Starbucks and on
time no I'm going there to work it's
like I'm gonna see my friends I'm gonna
you know be distracted and you know you
never know what's gonna happen so it's
it there is some definitely some wisdom
to having like it's a writing space
that's like an office you know so that's
that's kind of I'll do that at some
point I haven't done that yet but you
know I'll have a place where I'll have
like an office that's just a separate
you know building aside from where I'm
you know where I'm living right yeah I
was always opposed to coffee shop
writing for the longest time and then I
noticed that if you have headphones on
and you can still sort of see what's
going on around you it actually is
invigorating yeah yeah whatever you're
working on even if you're not
screenwriting you're just working on
something right
we have headphones those are important
because those people just come here
talking to you oh that's true yeah it's
a good mother it's a good social buffer
yeah but also libraries too I mean I'm
just surprised that actually it does
feed you and why I was opposed to it for
the longest time and I I can tell now
why people need to get out of the house
cuz you got a you you need that little
segue from being in your home to your
brain going hey we're going to work now
it's hard to you know if I'm just going
for my bedroom to the living room it's
hard to just sit over here and say okay
turn on my work brain because I'm like
wait what's on TV and I'm gonna take a
nap really quick and yeah right or if I
see an interesting article on like
Flipboard or pocket or something and
then I'm like let me just read this and
then and I'm distracted so yeah what you
get to rail then it's kind of right you
get to work here the focus back again
would you say you're very disciplined
when you know that you need to get these
four things done that you're pretty good
yeah I think my friends think I'm more
discipline than I am like I think I
could probably more disciplined I I do
work hard though but it's it's um I
guess I am I guess I am but in my brain
I'm not disciplined enough and my
friends like you're so disciplined I'm
like that I feel like it'd be done more
if I was more disciplined but I'm
usually always juggling a lot at the
same time so but you always always want
to make sure you don't have more on your
plate than you can like really dedicate
quality time to so I've definitely
learned the art of saying no as I've
gotten older because when you're young
you want to say yes to everything
because you think oh this could be my
you know these three opportunities could
be the only things I ever get so you're
always like saying yes to everything and
as you get older you start realizing
like you know it's okay to say no to
stuff if you're not passionate about it
or if you don't think you'll have the
time to to really do it and I've done
that where I'm like this really isn't my
thing and I don't think I'm the best
writer for it so you know I know a lot
of writers it will take you know jobs
just to have a job and I'm Ellis I think
it's something that I could do justice
to I'm not going to take it on as a it's
a job unless it's a challenge but
sometimes there have been things where
people have brought me projects where
I'm like this isn't in my wheelhouse but
it would be really fun to try to write
it so then I'll do that but it's got to
be something that really strikes a chord
with me do you know any writers that
write 8-10 hours a day yeah yeah yeah
okay so do they usually I mean I'm
assuming they stop for lunch or they do
something yeah yeah I mean yeah I know
that I have a lot of writer friends that
they they do if they're not on staff
there they're very much like they treat
it like a nine-to-five job so they'll
you know get the morning they'll do
their thing they little right to lunch
time they'll take lunch so we're right
till 5:00 and they'll stop writing for
the day and that's again that's I think
that's great if you're if you're working
on one thing at a time you have the
luxury of doing that more I think if
you're trying to do two or three
projects at the same time then it's
harder to to do that but you can do it
you know I certainly have friends that
have that that do it you know what are
some of the most important questions
you're asking yourself when you're
developing a story idea I think who my
audience is you know it's a story
interesting enough usually for my horror
stuff it's like is there enough is there
enough stuff in here to care about the
characters but am I also coming up
enough scare so we haven't seen before
those are the kind of things I ask
myself like it's interesting cuz I I
love doing it and I've done it for so
long that it's it's definitely it's not
easy work at all like people because
people don't understand like again
especially when you're threading a
script together and you know dissecting
and making sure that everything kind of
lines up in pieces together you want to
put your best foot forward but you also
realize that a lot of times that once
you sell the script and it's out of your
hands a lot of that stuff just goes out
the window
so that's why I'm not as harsh when I
see a movie I like that I reserve
judgment on the writer until I see read
the actual screenplay because you just
never know what changes from page to
screen but for me it's usually
especially because it's always horror or
films it's like you know do I think this
is also do I think this is going to
strike a chord of people like you know
fundal assassination dealt with death
which is kind of a universal fear so I
try to think of concepts that will tap
into something that's will reach a wide
audience you know I'm not gonna lie
about that like I do try it you know you
you want to hit as many people as you
can I think with your concept but that's
what I love about horror of the horror
genre I think themes are you know the
fears that we have most people are
universal fears that are
you know regulated to like one region or
one part of the world or or any but you
know I think we all kind of have the
same fears deep down so that's one thing
I think I love about horror is you can
kind of tackle a whole bunch of
different kind of stories and still have
it play well around the world
I like how you use the analogy if it's
like knitting you know and that if you
you know how let's suppose you're
knitting or crocheting something and
then you just pull one little string
here that it can really affect the whole
like you know yeah
sweater or whatever right no people
don't realize that when they it's just
when they give you know it's the
like I I know at one time I had a
project where a director came in the
producers were all literally like we
think he's full of but we're gonna
give him a shot directing because he
directed a couple things before but his
pitch he kind of came in and had an
opening scene that was because the movie
hope the whole movie built around this
plot twist about these characters not
knowing each other and his opening scene
was basically it was very clear these
characters into each other and so you
know my first meeting with him I was
like well you know I was trying to be
very diplomatic well how do you propose
that we how do you propose that we do
that opening scene so that we don't
spoil the fact that they know each other
because that's kind of the whole twist
of the script and it was somewhat one
that's well you're the writer you figure
it out and so it's like okay you're
that's like the you know I will spoil
the end of usual suspects oh if you
haven't seen that but that's like that's
like going you know pretend that's you
know Kevin Spacey didn't make it all up
in size or Kyser so he's a real person
but you like but the whole point of the
movie is is in and then they are like or
you know the end of the sixth sense it's
like well pretend Bruce Willis is like a
real person and not a guy you notice so
you know when that when they come to do
something like that it gets it's a
little they obviously don't understand
like you're you're taking the core of
what makes this movie like the core
mystery and you're giving it away at the
beginning so that's going to change the
whole movie and then there's ice okay
you'll figure it out so it's just shows
a certain level of not understanding
about you know how much thought you do
need to actually put into a good
screenplay and then when you said
something earlier about you know that
even something that you write that you
are Precious about at some point there's
like a
letting go process because you know that
once it's sort of out of your hands it
could be changed yeah yeah and you have
to you have to and I think that's
another you know kind of blessing of
working in a studio as I got to see that
they're you know even though you know
again Newland was very much about you
know artists and then and you know
protecting their vision and things like
that there were a lot of times where you
know we would get a script in it had
like Jim Carrey attached to it and there
was another script that came in with
nobody attached but it was a great
script well they're gonna go with the
Jim Carey script first obviously and so
that's just part of the business so
there's so many decisions it's just like
with acting like it's so much different
when you sit in an audition room than
when you're going into audition because
you know obviously the people in the
room they don't know how much time that
you've audition and how much you know
you've taught - you've audition for your
friends and you've taped it you've got a
you know you've hacked in coaches like
coach you down line delivery and you're
seeing and on the other side of the
table when actors come in and they leave
and it's like you know that was the best
actor but you know his hair color the
same as the other two guys that we have
and you know it's like what we could dye
his hair and then it's like yeah yeah
but then it you know and then some of
the smallest things will like be the
deciding factor and it has nothing to do
with a person's talent so you have to
learn to detach at a certain point
otherwise you just you know because of
the business no matter what part of the
business you work and you're gonna get
more nose and yeses like it's it's it's
it's to get somebody else to make
everybody it's easy to make your own
movie now because you have that you can
make a movie on your iPhone it looks
professional it's high-definition now
but you know it's almost impossible if
you think about the odds of getting
someone else to put up money to make
your movie so getting a movie made in
and of itself is a miracle it really is
so to think about that and then how hard
it is to get cast for something you know
for every role that you know when we put
out a casting thing forever oh we'll get
like 500 you know people that are
submitted for like one role and you have
to narrow those all down to people that
come across good on tape to the people
that you actually call in to them to the
rooms and then you Whittle those people
down and you bring them in for chemistry
reads and there been so many times where
it's like we had two great actors that
we love for a part but when you get them
together they just had no chemistry
whatsoever and then the these two actors
you know that we didn't think we're as
great as ones
before come in and have great chemistry
and you're like you know it makes you
rethink the whole thing so so yeah that
was a long answer about letting go but
you have to kind of let that that has
that filters over into any any probably
any part of your life you know because
we all no matter what we do for a
profession like we put you know we kind
of identify ourselves by that so we
identify our or well our well our value
by how well we do in it so you know if
you no matter what you do
whether it's you know you're a doctor or
lawyer or whatever if you're not
succeeding then there's a part of you
that feels like you're a failure and you
have to realize like so much stuff is
out of your control all you can do is
your best like that's why I like writing
because even you know acting is even
worse because you don't have any say
over auditioning like you you don't know
if you're in addition but at least with
writing I can write like nobody can stop
you
you know from physically writing all the
time so like that's one thing I have
control over so you can only have you
can only worry about this if you have
control over and do your best but there
are so many things outside of your
control that have nothing to do with
your talent and and oftentimes we do
think it you know if we don't get apart
or if we don't get a writing assignment
or if our movie doesn't get greenlit
we're like it's because we suck or
writing sucks well you know but and you
know I'm sound like and that's that's
just a common feeling I think we have as
human beings about stuff if we don't
succeed at something we think it's a
personal failure you know for us as a
human being like we're failing when it's
really not that at all it's just there's
so many other things that we can not we
have no idea that factor into that you
know final decision about what gets
going or what movie gets made or who
gets cast did you always think like that
I mean because that's a pretty mature
way of looking at it and I don't know
does that just come with having been
rejected or having seen the industry
from the time when you were 19 working
at new line I think it was a little bit
I think it was seeing an industry from
when I think those who partly same
industry from when I was 19 I think part
of us how I was was raised Who I am
my mom was very you know very much an
you know she a single mother raised me
and my sister but she was very much
about us getting education we we were
biracial we grew up in it really not
accepting part of
America when we I mean while all of
America wasn't very accepting we were
first born so you know we were in you
know we were raising the Baha'i faith
which is very much about like unity of
the whole world of equality of men and
women and races and equality of religion
and so I've definitely mom is always in
you know just that upbringing has always
taught me to think about the bigger
picture you know like a you know I feel
and it's it's not doesn't make me any
smarter or any better or wiser than
anybody it's just that you know I grew
up thinking about the world community as
if as opposed to like just you know my
town and you know my country it's like I
you know of course I love my country but
I realized that our country was part of
a big world and it seems like a lot of
people didn't quite start realizing it
until the internet came along and they
start going on there's a whole world out
there of other people that were
connected to so I've always tried to and
it's it's it's been to my benefit and to
my detriment like I always try to see
like all sides of an issue I try to you
know I have friends from every
background and on the planet you know
some people that are that are hardcore
like 80s and people that are hardcore
religious and people that are right wing
and left wing and you know people that
you know and because I because I the one
thing that my mom always taught us
growing up is in again it's you know
being born in 69 you know that was when
the last school was there was the last
school was desegregated in 69 so you
know people people tend to kind of
forget how we haven't had as much time
from a lot of the ugliness that we think
we'd like to think that we do and so I
got to see a lot of that firsthand
growing up but my mom was always like
don't judge these people by what they're
doing now because they're only treating
you how they were taught to treat you
this isn't defining who they are and so
you have to like you know pray for them
and wish them well and not do that so I
tried I try to take that approach with
everything and sometimes myself and
Santa I fail miserably at it a lot of
times too but I think that that taught
me at a young age just is so not to
separate but just to kind of see a
bigger picture kind of point of view
because I I knew you know I wasn't thing
so we're always gonna be horrible like
you know and when I was like facing
racism growing up and
you know on top of that then I came out
being gay and it was like well we can't
call them this word but now we can call
them this other word now and then you
know so it's just it's so you see people
just kind of replacing you know
prejudices with other prejudices and it
all comes from places of like fear and
you know and and ignorance I don't mean
that in an educated way but just you
know when people don't aren't exposed to
something like I sure I did it to a
podcast the other day and the topic was
but you're not like you're not like the
rest of them and that's what I heard a
lot of times growing up where people
there were racist or like oh but you're
not like the rest of those black people
are you know the rest of those gay
people didn't though you just say all
these horrible like stereotypes about
them so it's it's interesting when you
see the world kind of from that
perspective is a little bit of an
outsider who is trying to understand
like all the sides of something because
you realize a solution lies in the
middle somewhere and not screaming at
this side or this side and that there
really aren't two sides it's just you
know it makes us feel better if we're
like fighting against somebody is to
pose to trying to like look for a
solution so that kind of thinking has
just been that was inbred in me I'm not
an bred in me but you know and saying
like that was kind of it still I'm a
writer emotional I'm sure to bring those
yeah I mean yeah but that was instilled
at me from a young age mom always taught
me that the world is bigger than me and
bigger than what was what was in my
immediate vicinity so like you know even
if I was going through a rough time and
you know growing up in like you know
priests middle school and things like
that is she's like you know there's a
world beyond that that you're gonna get
to at some point and you know and I just
you know so that's always taught me just
not to internalize stuff as much but the
bad side is that now I'm my life I am
very much a people pleaser where I want
to make everybody happy and I want to I
want everybody to get along because it
really is such a simple it's so it just
is simple sometimes just sitting down
and listening listening with somebody
instead of talking and I talk a lot
because I'm a writer so I'm you know I
always joked like we don't interact that
much with people because we're always in
front of it in front of our laptops so
it's hard to shut us up when you get us
out there but but when you actually you
know that's why I'm able to have friends
with so many different beliefs because I
actually sit down and we don't agree on
everything but it's so funny when you
like people there's a there's automatic
defenses that they go to when you talk
about certain topics and things and so I
know Sartre because I see them people
just fall into those defenses all the
time so then I always try to figure out
how to talk around those and how to you
know I'm saying not to it's like when
you have a sibling I love my sister to
death but she knows how to push my
buttons so it's like when she pushes a
button I can either react in a different
way or I can react the way that I've
reacted for my whole life
and say the same thing back to her that
I always say that I was gonna start a
big fight you know what I'm saying so
that's kind of how I view life is to is
like you know if you're when you're
going through life it's like dealing
with people dealing with situations it's
like you could see it's easy to get
caught up in the emotion of that moment
and react and I feel like I'm like going
off tangent here now but do you put in
your scripts I mean especially being in
a town where there is such a maybe a
look of like this is the right way this
is not the right way and feeling like
that Outsiders I think that shapes a lot
of artists in a very intense way you
think you've got a lot of that in your
script um I don't I I don't put a lot I
think I think I try to be much I think I
try to just write stuff and then have
the inclusivity like speak for itself
even the love that gets taken out of my
scripts like I I'll write scripts that
have like people from different you know
racial backgrounds or you know most of
my scripts except for a finalist session
you know or very you know strong women
I'm at the center of it like I haven't
written none of my scripts of had nudity
and them just because I don't think I
need it now sequels have you know but
for me it's like I don't think I don't
think I need it unless it's you know I
did there was a butt shot in my last
movie but it was it was tastefully done
oh good um and it was from afar I was
just maybe walking out of the bathroom
but but you know the so I try to like
it's more like I don't because I never
wanted because I write horror movies I
mean I kill people on screen so it's
like I you know I can't really you don't
want to get too preachy with messages
you know like in fun ELISA nation I mean
you could say yes it's you know you
never know how long you have to live so
enjoy life while you can but but on top
of that I know that I can write like you
know a really you know hopefully complex
like female character
or I can write a gay characters not a
stereotype or I can you know have a
Muslim character in there a lot of times
again these characters get taken out
after I've sold a script so I've had to
learn to kind of let that go and I'm you
know moving more into directing and
producing now so that I can kind of put
that stuff back in there because for me
it's just about showing people as people
and I think that's how you break down
walls and it's it's sometimes it's
easier it's kind of a joke that does tie
into the topic but it's like you know
I've been sober for like 11 years now
and and I noticed that every time so all
my friends every time somebody gets
sober like all three scripts always then
have somebody who's either an alcoholic
or just got sober and their scripts like
it and I you know it's just because all
of a sudden you feel like when you you
don't realize how prevalent alcoholism
is even though you're not supposed to
ever diagnose anybody else is being
alcoholic it has to be self diagnosed
but you just never realize how prevalent
alcohol is you know until you get sober
and then it's like you go to a party
that's sponsored by a Skyy Vodka and
then you're like can I just get a coke
and they're like seven dollars I'm like
but you're giving away vodka cranberries
for free yeah but that's our sponsor I'm
sober
I don't care seven dollars so you don't
realize how much alcohol is like pushed
on you until you don't drink anymore so
when something like that catastrophic
happens in your life when like when you
quit something you know like that then I
think a lot of times you'll find rioters
like we'll put that in our in our stuff
or we'll bring it up and you know but I
think the outsider thing in general is
what is a kind of a common theme you'll
find amongst tour writers in general is
I think that you know a lot of them were
like weren't the super popular kids you
know and there's some really I mean in
there and there are some writers that
already I know that we're really popular
you know and we're prom king and queen
so but a lot of them weren't you know a
lot of them were like the kind of comic
geeks and the people that like to you
know just go off and do geeky things and
not not but not play the sports and try
to be popular kind of people so it's a
pretty eclectic mix but but yeah I think
you just everybody does there does their
thing I have some female horror writers
who some of the stuff that I read of
there is I'm like wow this is actually
has more nudity and leering at women
than if a straight guy wrote this like
wait a minute you said this is a
feminist
right I know it oh but I guess maybe
you're you know like I can't speak for
but I know writers that will try to make
sure that they put a message you know
like in their movies or something that's
really important and for me it's more
like just trying to like I have a movie
outlines get right now that's got it
pretty much in like a 95%
african-american Latino cast and it's
not about it's just a hormone it's a
slasher movie and I just tell people
it's just like if you're watching screen
where it's like a bunch of pretty white
kids and there's like well not even the
first one they didn't have any black
people in the first one but you know one
of the later screams were you're
watching a bunch of pretty white kids
and they have like the one black friend
as our movies like you're just focusing
on all the pretty black and Latino kids
and they have a couple of white friends
so it's it's not that you're making a
movie that's about race it's just you're
casting a movie that's just focusing on
a different group of friends than most
of the horror films do so I think that
that that type of movie in my humble
opinion will actually reach a wider
market because again you know white
audiences just want to go see a good
horror movie you know like they don't
care what color they the characters are
and then people of color who are
horribly underrepresented in horror
films are a huge audience for horror
films we've just done all the tests even
at new line we did test marketing back
and you know the 90s and it was like in
all the major cities it was like 50
percent you know the audiences in
all the major cities were African
American Latino and it's such a horribly
underserved market that they'll go to
see the movie numerous times because
they've never seen themselves
represented on screen it's just people
and regular horror fans and not
recognize it's awful I'm trying to be so
PC right now screw that I'm most snow
flake you know but you know a horror fan
white fans and songs is a good
slasher movie they're gonna go see a
couple times too so that's gonna be a
really good kind of social experiment
and it's taken me like 20 you know I've
been trying since I tried to have a you
know black leading one of the final
destination movies and it isn't it never
happened and um you know so it's taking
me like yeah that's taking me 20-some
years to like finally get a movie going
you know so it's it is it's funny when
we when we talk about you know were
races and is it an American it's like oh
we're you know we voted for Obama so
we're post-racial now and everything's
hunky-dory and it's like
yeah it's not you know it's like kids
cuz you know Holly was pretty frigging
liberal but they they know what sells
and what won't sell and they know how
people like pigeonhole kind of movies
and sometimes they do underestimate
definitely they underestimate people's
intelligence in a way or what they'll go
see but there there's just also the hard
reality that you have to prove to them
like I'm gonna be like girl triple that
came out with Jada Pinkett and Queen
Latifah and you know makes thirty
million dollars opening weekend and
they're like wow you know and Wonder
Woman comes out directed by a woman and
about a woman superhero what they act so
surprised and it's like nobody wants to
take a chance on something that's
different so you have to you have to
find that person that will or that
studio that will and then once you do I
guarantee you once this movie comes out
there's gonna be a whole bunch of you
know slasher horror films that are like
you know heavily like diverse cast so so
again it's kind of like a quiet fight
you know I haven't been running around
like you know yelling after every fun
listen he comes out when I wanted a
black character to be the lead and they
wouldn't like I you know that's not
gonna do me any good that's just gonna
upset people and make people think that
I'm like crying grace you don't say like
it's not gonna be productive so you just
kinda have to put your put your best
foot forward to put your money where
your mouth is and try to do you find
that people that like kind of get behind
the movie like the one that we're doing
now so did you try to add a non-white
character to any of the final destiny
yeah and and what would happen oh they
would just cast a white person so they
you would write it into the script yeah
as to who this character was and then
when you saw the final product yeah and
it you know it was Friday and the the
the reality is is internationally movies
if the lead is a person of color they
don't sell as as well internationally
and you know I get except for like if
you know like Halle Berry or Denzel
Washington or there's you know there's a
there's there's like maybe five names
that will in certain genres will sell
internationally but you know movie like
get out comes out and it makes a hundred
million here and it only cost like five
million to make it's like who cares what
it makes internationally like you're
gonna make that money here so there
there is a little bit of business
reasoning behind it
a lot of its like until you you try to
break the mold you never know what the
mold you know you never know until you
try to break the mold and you know
that's why I think this last year with
get out and Wonder Woman we're so
important is because even though I even
I'm on my facebook before it came out
I'm like I'll bet my life that one Iran
is gonna be one of the top selling you
know superhero film so all time and it's
just because people don't they
underestimate how powerful of an impact
Lynda Carter had his Wonder Woman so
pretty much everybody you know in their
forties you know 50 you know and above
and you know late 30s anybody who kind
of grew up on seeing Lynda Carter as
Wonder Woman love that character and
she's been around forever
and then you got younger people meeting
her in the Justice League so I knew the
movie was gonna do like huge business
but nobody you know it's like when
people say oh if an openly gay actor
were to play a you know like James Bond
nobody believed it I'm like why don't we
try it first
you know like cuz I I think people that
go watch movies like know that Robert
England's not a you know child molesting
serial killer that wears you know I'm
sure I'm sure that they know he's not
like that in real life so I don't know
if this is it's funny so you just try to
make whatever changes you can with your
art and a lot of times it doesn't even
happen and again I work in the horror
genre so for you know again it's it's
even more it's even harder to try to
like you know you don't want you can't
get too high-minded in you know in a
horror film you can you know again you
can try to again make strong female
characters you know make interesting
dynamics between between everybody you
know showed the diversities of just
people of any like religion or
background and you know you can try to
put all that in your movie but a lot of
times that ends up getting out of your
hands you know once you sell the script
so you just kind of again that's when
you learn to kind of let go and you know
be grateful you had a movie made you
know can you think of an example where
you wrote yourself into a corner and
then how you wrote yourself out yeah
yeah I'm pretty easy Tamra was it movie
I wrote myself into a corner because it
was um you know like that's a tough
thing in horror films as you create your
your villainy you make them really
strong and it's like you have to come up
with a way to stop them
and you don't want to do something super
generic but you know Tamara was kind of
my homage to carry about a girl who's
picked on and bullied and these kids
pull a prank on it makes identity killer
and she's you know in the description
supposed to be like really frumpy and
unattractive and then they bearer in the
woods and the next Monday she comes into
school she's really smoking hot and she
knows all their secrets and their sins
and she uses that to turn against them
but I made her you know she was really
powerful and so I'm like you know how if
I stop her it's either gonna have to
find a spell since using the witch
Heather had find a spell to stop or
which is kind of you know it's just
we've seen that a hundred times like how
am I gonna and I made her so strong that
you can't kill her because she came back
from the dead so what do you know what
do I do and so I had the if you haven't
seen Tamara spoiler but no but so I
basically had the you know I tied her
fate to the teacher that she was in love
with so he ended up sacrificing you know
doing the heroic sacrifice and like you
know grabs Tamara and jumps off a
building with her and you know
sacrifices himself to stop her so you
know heroic sacrifice is always a good
way and a to get yourself out of a
corner because you that's the thing when
you create a monsters you had to figure
out a way to kill it and then it's like
you don't want it to be something overly
complicated but you don't want to be
something as simple as a spell just
killer so yeah that I would definitely
wrote myself into a corner on with that
movie and I was like well I'll I'll just
yeah I'll have a teacher you know
sacrifice his life to stop her and then
when you got notes let's say the first
few times around showing them what we're
what were the notes what would the
feedback about Tamara like was she too
much this not enough this Tamara was
actually Tamara's probably the easiest
that was probably the easiest project to
as far as you know we found a studio
that wanted to do and they did it like
it was um it was pretty easy easy so cuz
I wrote that one cuz I want to have fun
with the movie because I already been
like bringing something like final
destination bring us something and they
you know that's yeah and then you bring
this something L this too much like
final destination it's like stop like so
if I just wanted to write something fun
and like in my MI
and you know it was just like a fun I
wonder I like a fun like quotable like
can't be sexy you know horror movie I
mean it turned out really well I did
joke because we because of the budget
you know we hit we had we had a certain
budget and then magically half that
budget like disappeared um before when
we started shooting so the movie turned
out not you know we didn't have the
money that we went in the movie having
so I was kind of joke it's kind of like
the pg-13
you know ABC Family version of an
r-rated horror film that I wrote so when
you watch it you can definitely see like
a lot of places where it's like this
story that kind of chopped out a little
bit and then stuff didn't go like wow
they could have really pushed the
envelope here and they played it really
safe and that was that was all because
of like you know budget stuff or things
like that so that was another one where
like I actually wrote a book with a
friend of mine
JD Matthews him we put it out just based
on the screenplay so that people could
see like what the original story was
like because if the only thing we had to
change on that because there were some
pretty intense stuff in there but nobody
ever said take it out but and that's
what's always funny because a lot of
times it's the studio that wants you to
take out stuff and play it safe and the
couple movies were odd that's happened
to me it hasn't been the studio that's
done it it's been like either a producer
like kind of running off with some money
or or yeah or or somebody on the on the
movie set like oh no this is yeah let's
tone this down let's do this so I've had
the opposite of what a lot of people
have where it's like the studio wants to
play it safe like I had a couple movies
row I'm I can't believe they're letting
me get away with this and then you get
on set and one of the actors like I
don't want to do this and then they're
like okay no Mike damn it it's like
usually the studio stops me not an actor
so it's a very again it's very it's a
very interesting business that we're in
so having final destination and and the
various ones that you were a part of
under your belt do you think that
sometimes it's difficult because they
pigeonhole you is that and you want to
do something and a little bit of a
different realm or it is it nice because
you're known for that so then they have
confidence I mean for me it's nice I
mean just because I've I'm a horror fan
and I'll probably you know I've you
I have a science-fiction kind of horror
overtones to it but a big science
fiction project right now we're doing
but you know I might branch out a little
bit but I'm very happy writing horror so
I've just yeah I love the genre so and I
used to in part of its like also from
just growing up you would read in
Fangoria magazine which is like the
Bible for for people but you know you'd
read directors they would do a horror
film they're like well it's not really a
horror film it's more of a supernatural
thriller and they would try to say
everything but say it's a horror film
and then they would do a horror film
because they know they're gonna probably
make a profit and then they would quit
making horror and go off and do other
stuff so I've even directors to be like
well this is really a stepping-stone to
do what I want to do and so growing up
you get really like screw you you know
this is a great Jean ruisseau you know
and it is and so yeah this is something
I am very you know embrace holy I love
going to horror conventions and and yeah
it's just a lot of fun it's a lot of
fantasy there's a great it's a great fan
base and you know a lot of the you know
the people that I work with now that are
my peers were all horror fans like me we
grew up loving the same stuff and
watching the same stuff so it's a really
fun community to be a part of Jeffrey
will you write on days when you don't
feel inspired yeah yeah I mean I always
joked my inspirations I had to pay rent
and I have to yeah I have bills to pay
so that's yeah you yeah you I mean there
are but there are times where I will
just I will give myself a break because
I'm like okay I've been working you know
I've been writing every day for ten days
and if I want to take a day off it's
okay like so that's that's usually what
happens with me it's like I don't it's
yeah I learned to not do it I because I
read a great quote somewhere tonight and
I some making Google and find out who
said it but they were talking about how
you know people you don't wait for your
muse to come you know like you grab the
muse and you strap it down to the chair
and you choke it until it you know we're
because yeah you will writers will find
any excuse to not write you know will
you know it's like working out or doing
anything that's that you want to do but
you're a little like a fearful that
you're not going to reach out for it
you're gonna find any excuse to put off
writing so you have to learn like not to
you know you can't say whether you're
waiting for inspiration because you can
inspire yourself if you start writing
even if
you write a call pages a day even if
it's crap you just train your brain to
write so it's you know it's a chemical
thing that you do if you make yourself
write every day at a certain time I
don't do this because I again roll out
of bed and we'll start writing pretty
early but you know I during the earlier
times there were what you know when I
was kind of like I don't feel inspired I
would just do that I would just get up
and be like alright I'm going to square
write two pages even if it's like awful
stuff and then you're you do actually
get your brain wired to where you'll
that those two hours will start coming
in your brain will start percolating
before before noon hits and you'll start
writing and you know so you it you have
to kind of train yourself to do it but I
understand like I understand that I
don't feel inspired today or whatever
but there comes a point where you have
to make sure you're not just doing that
because you're afraid of writing because
you you know I was talking to a friend
mine recently and you know she was
complaining about how she's like she's
written this you know you mungus outline
this humongous tree before and she just
hasn't started a script and I said well
because you know when you finish the
script you have to give it off and it's
like you're one step closer to like
handing over people so you're like stuck
in this this area and a lot of times
that's why we're procrastinating because
we know once we start writing and we
finish that script we have to give it to
somebody you know and that's when the
judgment comes so I think that that's
all the time the reasons that you know
that's where that not feeling inspired
is just like I think that's just kind of
not wanting to write really also -
because you're close to your characters
and I'm not sure if this is the same for
horror genre but that you
you're losing your friends in some sense
because that's who you've been spending
time with right so handing it off is
like almost ending a relationship
ya know it's it there is a weird place
you get when you write something you
love it and you're yeah in and you want
to hand it off and you want people that
read or read it to just love it as much
as you do and if they don't immediately
you're like you know yeah there's like a
it's like you're saying goodbye you're
ending something but then then it's like
sending them off and having oh people I
can go why were you in a relation with
that thing that's enough hideous choice
for a partner what were you thinking so
you don't want people to like not like
your stuff to when you hands it off so
it's um you it's it's like when you
audition when you go up in an audition
in front of people that you don't know I
mean
you're you're putting yourself up there
and basically even if you're being a
character or though you still feel like
you're like all right love me and want
me for this part and if you say no then
you're rejecting me so this you know
that's that's just something it's it's
really hard to like no matter how
successful you get or how long you've
been around it's hard to let that go you
know even now I like if I get a pass on
a script you know it still stings a
little bit even if it's a place that you
know it's not right for you know would
you say screenwriting is hard because
I'm sure a lot of people could look at
your story they could look at your
credits and you make it look easy in
terms of wow that's a really cool story
here you were 14 and you send this you
know script idea off and although it's
rejected and you don't know what the
notes are you still have this
relationship that really shaped you in a
lot of ways and I think it's a really
cool story and not a lot of people
probably have that opportunity but it is
it hard because it looks easy yeah from
the outsiders yeah it's it's it's hard
it's it's always interesting cuz if
sometimes if I if I have a story that I
love and I've outlined it then it's just
fun but when you're again when you're
definitely trying to do a lot of things
and get a lot of things like because
then you know you know I'm at the point
my career now where I want to you know
just branch out and tell you know still
horror stories but like do something
like the Lionsgate project which is you
know I think gonna it's just a really
important kind of thing that you've you
know where you had to fight for it it is
hard because you want to you you you
want to write something that's gonna
strike a chord to people who you want to
write something that's successful you
want to write something that's going to
spawn a franchise and and I've had you
know for better for worse for some of my
films they've done really well and other
ones that we're supposed to turn out
well didn't quite turn out the way
they're supposed to and what you know
directive video or didn't get a good
release and you know there's so there's
again there's it's you definitely have
to stay in gratitude a lot of times and
you have to find the joy in it all you
know in the joy in writing and I still
love writing especially when I'm you
know if I'm writing something else and I
get something this inspires me to like
you know like this
I hate to say it kills thing but you
know I could kill I'm like oh my god I
remember like I just thought of a great
scene for a movie that you know I was so
excited and I called the producer about
and he's like was in love with it and so
that's a fun stuff you know I was like
trying to come up with new new things
but you know it is hard to sit down in
front of the computer every day and you
know writing a hundred page script you
know that's it is it is work and it's
and it's not it's not easy you know
because you're you're trying to write
something that is going to be creatively
satisfying you're trying write something
that you think will sell because this is
your livelihood so you're trying to
juggle both of those things but not get
too far down the road that you're not
focused on the finishing the actual
script you know so you've got to keep
all those other things out of your or
try to keep them out of your head about
is this gonna sell is it's gonna make
money or people gonna like this yeah
they try not to like focus too much on
that and just get the script done but
that can be hard in and of itself you
know it's not future tripping about you
know what's gonna happen with the script
once you're done with it so it's um it's
fun but it's not easy it's not easy and
there are hard you know it's always it's
like with actors you know when because
acting is not easy to be a good actor is
not easy but you know you know it's not
like we're going into you know putting
out fires and you know putting our lives
in danger and you know doing like
physically hard labor it's just mental
it's just mental exhaustion you know
it's a lot a lot of mental work did this
screenwriting career that you envisioned
look the same in terms of the day-to-day
because you know how people have a
romantic notion about what something is
really I see you know no not at all yeah
yeah because you don't you don't really
envision with the writing like I
you don't realize how long it takes to
write a script first of all and then you
know like I you know I had a friend once
who was like oh yeah I just took a took
a weekend trip to Hawaii and wrote my
script on the beach with some mai tais
I'm like oh that's what writing is you
just go out for a weekend and you write
a script and ya know the day-to-day
grind of getting you know two or three
or four or five pages a day done is like
it's a it's a grind and then you've also
got life that you're living and you also
have to try to get out and have a life
because if you don't have a life you
know like I'm kind
because we are you know writers or some
very solitary but you know I do go out
to the movies and I do go out to dinner
I do go out and do stuff with my friends
because otherwise if you sit at home all
the time you're not experienced in life
and so then you can't bring anything
else to your scripts than what you've
already experienced so you're just kind
of regurgitating the same experiences
that you've had so you've got to kind of
make sure your cup is like flowing over
with other things besides just work but
you have to take time out to do that too
so in terms of what most people would
have envisioned like you know you're at
the keyboard and you've got it
well not a drink but you know some
people in you know they think that
that's part of with the cigarette and
just like this toilet existence oh yeah
and you're pounding out and then this
thing is beautiful in it but it sounds
like it's it's there's more of a science
to it and it's not just there's a
science but for some people again
everybody has a different method which
is is very interesting it's like it's
like with acting like you have your
method actors who have to be like you
know they have to become the character
and they have to you you have other
actors who when the camera when the
director says you know rolling you know
then they just they they go and then cut
then they drop back and who they are and
I think they're writers that are the
same way to like you know yeah there's a
stereotype that's why I quit drinking
it's like I was becoming that serotype
is something here drinking at home and
you know thinking I'm writing some
brilliant stuff and yeah the first
couple pages were great and then the
rest of its like what the hell was I
writing so you know you think you do
think that that's kind of I do have some
friends that do torture themselves
without the drinking or anything they
just you know it's like they obsess
about every single line of dialogue and
it's like you're never going to finish
your script if you're like that but
again that's how they are so everybody's
got a whole different process and so
that's why I always tell people don't
don't judge yourself harshly if your
process isn't the same as somebody
else's you know because it really is
your end result that matters it's like
getting that script finished so you do
obviously have to follow certain you
know structural rules and certain you
know your dialogue needs to be good
you're you know it has to be an engaging
story but sometimes it takes people a
lot longer you know I've known friends
that where it's taken them 10 years to
write a script you know it's not they're
working every day 8 hours a day on it
but you know 10 years yeah yeah I had a
couple friends that have like yeah I've
been working on this for 10 years and
and it's great some of this stuff
great and I've read some scripts where
people have written script in a week and
it's great not consistently but you know
but it's everybody's got a different
thing and I think that's what's always
interesting too is we always have our
ideas in our head what everybody's life
is like and it's like you know even what
you think an actor's life is like like
it their lives you know the celebrities
lives I mean they're you know they were
like trudging into Starbucks with their
dog and their kids crying and have to go
change her kid's diaper and you know
just like everybody else is you know
like you know so you you definitely the
glamour of Hollywood that they used to
project and it was so important back in
the days of you know the olden days with
the with the Hollywood stars you know
which when it was like the stars ran
everything and they had to keep up these
perfect images like we've lost all of
that now with like the internet and
access to everybody's private lives and
you know we see people now on the street
you know people are taking pictures of
people and it's like oh wait I mean
they're just like a you know like that's
even a I think people are something has
a whole thing like celebrities they're
just like us and it shows pictures of
them like walking a dog and before that
you thought these are there were these
magical creatures and you know you
thought these writers were these like
tortured you know sitting in a dark room
like with you know just pounding away at
a keyboard and you know sipping from
their bottle of whiskey and you know
curse in the heavens and yeah it's it's
it's different for everybody assume for
everybody but they're all at Starbucks I
mean they definitely a coffee shops are
full of writers in California that's
definitely a cliche that you can't
that's one cliche that's true it's like
you go every coffee shop there's
somebody's work there's five people
working on the screenplay at any coffee
shop that you walk into so it's pretty
funny how much time do you spend
outlining a story I know you had talked
about a friend that had this like really
long outline and you and do keep it to
one page or how do you do it
um I usually do like maybe two or three
pages like I'll do like a super rough
outline and I'll just flush out a little
bit more and then try to write the
script after that because I I find that
most of the the fun stuff comes when I'm
writing so I definitely try to have
everything planned out as far as like
this is what's gonna happen in the story
and these are the characters they're
gonna make it to the end and you know
here's when this person you know I try
to plot all that stuff out but sometimes
I leave stuff open because it's when
you're writing it all of a sudden like a
lot of times you'll get and
fired by some fun stuff how do you get
better at writing was it through the
notes that you got when you think about
let's say you know being sixteen and
writing something versus now what do you
think was the main thing to really get
you better at it to really improve your
craft um I think it was just thought I
think it was reading scripts and also
that which you know you learned it
ferment to it positive is that insecure
feeling that you have that you know and
I know I hear people talk about this all
the time about like actors of whatever
they're always like the way they always
were it is like they're afraid that
someday somebody's gonna realize that
they were a fraud and they're not really
that good you know as an actor writer
and I think people that get better and
better with people that have that thing
and then where they're worried you know
that they're not good enough yet so they
strive harder so that's for me it's like
I think if I ever get to the point where
I'm like oh this is this is the best
horror script that's ever gonna ever be
done and so I've written it and I can
just quit now then I'm screwed because I
again I meet people like that all the
time or they're like trust me this is
gonna be the best movie you'll ever you
know and it's like it's not gonna be the
best movie ever you know don't say that
like if you guys get me aids so I think
that that drive to constantly get better
and top yourself as far as like the last
thing that you did like you know like
you know final destination I'm very
proud of that because it was kind of a
because it was it was a you know this is
the first time that death had actually
been like the killer in a film so you
know we you know it was a kind of a
benchmark kind of film like I'm just
trying to be nice but it was it made a
you know it has it definitely has a
bookmark in horror history so that's
enough of something to make me happy but
I want to you know with the Lionsgate
project evolved that to be another
bookmark as far as that was the first
you know studio release film with a you
know diverse cast and you know it's it's
my first slasher film too so I'm getting
back I'm on the slide or not back in but
I'm you know hopefully will kind of kick
that any new way with the slashers off
so now I actually know how I forgot the
point was they owe in terms of getting
better so it's not getting better
ya know it's it's you know I don't want
to I
always joke I don't want a milk final
destination yeah I don't want that to be
my graves don't like hero final
destination that's like you know my only
thing like so I wanna I want more I want
a couple more franchises before I die so
I know to do that I have to keep writing
and I know that I have to write good
stuff and you know hopefully something
will stick you know how many pilots or
TV series have you written pilots I have
five pilots we're out with two of them
right now two of them didn't get didn't
get picked up but there's always a shot
and then one I had option for a while
and then got it came back to me once the
company kind of changed their mandate so
say I've written five five pilots and um
that's fun I mean TV the great thing
about TV is you know they treat the
writers are kind of like at the top of
the food chain and TV which again is is
is how it should be just in general
because again unless somebody actually
writes something then everybody else
whether it's a director actors all the
crew like they would they don't have a
job unless there's something written
like so you know having a theater
background like you know the play was
always so important to us like even the
director was always like you know it's
about the written word and then you
moved to Hollywood and it's like writers
are below anybody hey the guys that
clean the toilets out you know it's just
I'm exaggerating a tiny bit but it
really is like you know directors actors
crafty you know gaffers and then the
writers like down here somewhere
because you know Hollywood there's
definitely again it's a perception of
what Hollywood's about and you know
there there came the time when the
auditor filmmakers started one and have
their names over everything so it was
like a film by Alfred Hitchcock so it's
like sound like oh it's all--it's Alfred
Hitchcock's movie the writer you know
doesn't matter at them and then it was
you know we have this cult of celebrity
to where it's like we you know we
idolize celebrities so then it's like
directors and the celebrities kind of
became the focal point of everything and
the writers kind of got a lot very lost
in the shuffle and then but when you get
in TV because you have to crank out the
work and they realize that it's the
writers that are actually cranking out
the work and then you know the directors
are hired on and the cast is hired on
but the whoever creates the show is
usually also an executive producer on it
has like creative control so that you
that's why you see a lot of people
moving again into television as well is
because it's you know they just treat
writers better it's just you know the
bottom line and they there's a just a
level of respect and it's not even about
ego like you want to be like you know
worshiped it is you know sometimes it
really literally is about you know just
respect like I had a friend of mine I
was talking to today and they had a they
had a cast and crew screening of the
movie he rode and didn't invite him
invited everybody else everybody and you
know and that's just kind of typical you
know this is typical of Hollywood and
you know it's things when you because I
guess already get a movie made and then
you write something and because of you
know politics or whatever it's like they
just don't invite the writer and it's
like so you know it's you know that's
not the only reason to get in TV there's
also something really gratifying about
writing something and it comes out like
a month later and you can watch it
whereas in movies God you can write
something and you know it never gets
made it gets made ten years from now 15
years from now it's gone through 20
other writers so by the time it ends up
on the screen you don't even see
anything that you wrote left in the
movie so there's something very
gratifying about TV because it the
turnaround is so much quicker from when
you finish the script to when it comes
out but um but yeah there is there is
just the the way they treat writers is
in T visas is is much cooler much more
appropriate than they doing it future
world a lot of times how many attempts
have you made to break into television
yeah I think maybe three really because
because the you know the two scripts
that I have now kind of gone out with
them at the same time and and they have
it hasn't really been a concerted effort
it's more like if I get an idea that I
feel is better suited for television
I'll do it but you know like there was a
time when I there was a time that I had
a project with a really big producer and
it was you know it was our project and
out of the project that she was focused
on the other project like got picked up
first and just took off and so then all
it sounds like well we can't really
focus on two at the time so it's like
you know you get you get a little bit
like yeah yeah but then you just keep
going and then you you know you but
again my foot my
focuses on features but I definitely am
interested in the TV world too because I
I just like how now there's so many
different ways you can write six episode
like event miniseries now or you can
write you know you know anthologies like
American Horror Story or you can write
you know a 22 but there's so many
different ways that you can write so
there's a different kind of stories you
can tell so I'm just interested in
exploring that world too and kind of
creating some of that's a little bit
more because I grew up watching TV all
the time too so it would be cool to have
something on TV as well when you finish
a screenplay what do you do well that's
a good question
um I usually take a nap no I do I do I
don't I don't go out do anything crazy
like celebrate I just I get I get very
happy and I'm like yes and I send it off
and I usually go take a nap because
especially when I'm in that last stretch
where something is either do or I'm
almost done that's when I start getting
a little like super Ayin where I'm going
back through everything and I'm
paginating the pages and you know one of
the tricks I learned is like you know to
try to have you know the last line of it
on a page be something where they have
literally make it a page-turner where
they have to turn the page to see what
the next page is gonna be like that was
a trick I learned from a friend of mine
and so you know I try to go through and
make sure like unless it's the very end
of a really great scene that it like
every end of every page is something
where you have to flip the page to at
least finish it because if you get them
over the next page they're probably
gonna keep reading it's like if you stop
them at at the end of a page with
something like but they may not turn the
next page so you know I do all those
like after I've worked on the script
itself then I do those like little like
you know mine gave me things to like
make sure it's a page-turner
so by the time I'm ready to send it off
and I have to go back to one more time
and I have you know then I take a nap
cuz I've I've wore myself a hot also -
is it a sense of accomplishment where
you feel like okay I can rest now yeah
I'm sure like up until a certain
deadline it might be a lot of sleepless
nights or maybe not it's nice and it's
stress but ya know when I when I finish
something there is definitely a sense of
accomplishment where you're like yes
especially if you if you know it's good
you know if you're not sure
then it's kind of like send with your
fingers crossed but I'm still gonna go
take a nap but then it's like but um but
yeah when you feel like you've really
nailed it it's good but that's again the
interesting about the business is you
can do a script that you're a hundred
percent confident in and your producer
loved it and then but one person in the
studio region is like me anything like
so again it's a rollercoaster ride it's
really you know that's why again I'm
very big on people like doing their own
content and trying to you know do your
own content because that's if you really
want to ensure something gets made done
the way you write it that's the best way
to do it but but yeah there's it's very
very gratifying when you type the end
and you mean it and you can hit Send
with whoever you have to turn the script
over - so it's you definitely feel like
good job so if you're not a writer for
hire for something it's your own like
passion project and you finish it then
what's your process then I usually try
to you know then I'll send it to you
know my agent or manager to look at and
then you know figure out like what place
is this into - or now what I've started
doing really because again I'm getting
more into like producing my own stuff is
you know connecting with some people
that I think have access to invest you
know more than into more the business
side of it like okay well this might be
good for this company these companies so
let's try to you know attach somebody or
let's try to you know now I've gotten
more business-minded I'm in the last
couple of years especially because um
again it's really you know I'd love to
someday be at the point where I'm
running my own company where I have like
assistants that can read a bunch of
scripts - and like we can make a whole
bunch of movies but you know right now
it's like a you know I I have some some
good stories that I want to tell and
something like all right I got to
maximize the chance to get those made so
that means if it's something that I've
written on my own a lot of times in
Latin now I'm going out and looking for
independent financing as opposed to
trying to get it set up somewhere so
that's been a fun like learning
experience in the last year or so